[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon it's my pleasure to
introduce and to welcome you to the
mit150 symposium on brains minds and
machines my name is David Mindell and
I'm chair of the mit150 steering
committee and I just wanted to say a few
words about mi t--'s 150th that provide
a little bit of context for today's
symposium in 1853 William Barton Rogers
came north from Virginia to pursue his
dream of a new kind of technical
education an education that would mix
the world of science and the useful arts
theory and practice what we have come to
know as men's at Manas or mind and hand
nine years later eight years later in
1861 the governor of Massachusetts
fulfilled Rogers dream by signing mi
t--'s charter on April 10th of last year
of that year creating this unique and
innovative educational institution now
150 years and two weeks later we're
celebrating mi t--'s accomplishments in
a whole variety of fields of ideas and
inventions that changed our world and
helped define it today and of the
courageous professors students graduates
and alumni who have gone forth from this
place to make their contributions to the
world the mit150 celebrations include
150 days of events concerts other
festivals today we're on the hundred and
17th day and we've already begun to see
over the past hundred and seventeen days
the emergence of tomorrow's MIT one
that's united by ambitious intellectual
agendas and focused on both its core
research domains and on the Institute's
relationship to the wider world within
the hundred fiftieth anniversary a
hundred that the intellectual core is a
series that comprises the core of MIT
thinkers students researchers and
professors
talking about great ideas contemplating
the world and perhaps even making a
little progress on some of the
interesting problems this is the essence
of the hundred and fifty symposia series
the sixth and last of which we're
opening today the other symposia have
focused on economics and finance back in
January conquering cancer through the
convergence of science and engineering
in March women's leadership in science
and engineering also at the end of March
computation and the transformation of
practically everything two weeks ago the
future of exploration in earth air ocean
and space last week and today's brains
minds and machines each of these
symposia were chosen for the leading
faculty the exciting ideas the new ideas
and the symposiums focus on more than
one department and more than one school
of course they in no way cover the full
range of the interesting research that
goes on at the Institute but they all
represent cutting-edge work that
epitomizes what is best about MIT
my thanks particularly today to
professor's Irina hime Tommy Poggio and
Josh Tenenbaum for their willingness to
step forward and organize this historic
gathering and to all of our participants
and all of you for taking the time to be
here to share your insights as well on a
personal note I find the symposium
particularly exciting not at least
because I spent a good deal of my career
studying the prehistory of cybernetics
and currently work on topics of human
and machine relationships and complex
systems but also because from the very
first pre-proposal that we reviewed on
the symposium it could we saw how it
coincides with the new intelligence
initiative NF MIT and represents a
genuinely new synthesis I could not
think of a better way to culminate the
mit150 symposium series than with this
event
nothing could better illustrate MIT
seminal history in these areas it's
synthetic intellectual culture and the
great promise for the future than what
you're about to see in the following two
days I'll now introduce the Dean of
science at MIT mark Casner thank you
and you David David said it well this is
an extremely exciting topic I love it in
particular because in addition to the
deep intellectual challenges it already
in the new intelligence initiative has
already involved faculty members from
all of the five schools at MIT the
School of Science with its brain and
cognitive science department School of
Engineering obviously but also the
School of Humanities Arts and Social
Sciences where linguistics and
philosophy and economics sit the Sloan
School of Business and the School of our
architecture urban planning which houses
the Media Lab so this is an intellectual
challenge which draws together faculty
members from all across MIT and and that
makes it very exciting so it has this
problem has a great history at MIT but
also has a great future at MIT I want to
add my thanks to professors time poggio
and Tenenbaum and a special thanks to
Laurie and Pat McGovern and the McGovern
Institute for hosting a reception
tomorrow so on with the show it should
be fun
[Applause]
so on behalf of my Corgan Iser Irene
Haim and Josh Tenenbaum and all the MIT
hundred-fifty organization and people of
my group that will be helping you around
in the next couple of days I would like
to welcome you to this imposing and to
this first panel of today we are in a
typical gritty MIT classroom we kept you
outside in the heat just to emphasize
the point we are very close to where the
old barracks were building 20 back in
the 50s and 60s there was a remarkable
intellectual activity in the old country
that started around the new physics and
engineering of electronics and
information processing and if MIT was
one of the main centers of this
whirlwind of activity building 20 was
really the center of it serving as a
magical incubators for a number of
fields as diverse as information theory
cybernetics neural networks linguistics
artificial intelligence and neuroscience
researchers in the building included
Claude Shannon Norbert Wiener Walter
Pitts McCulloch Nam Tomsky Maurice
Haller
Jarrell Edwin Marvin Minsky and the
intellectual ferment eventually
converged in the ambitious attempt to
understanding intelligence and
replicating it in computers and machines
Marvin Minsky and Seymour Papert were
key in starting the new field of
artificial intelligence norm scheme and
David Marr pioneered linguistics and
cognitive science and computational
neuroscience and I would like to
remember in particular Jarrell Edwin who
died about a week ago he was part of
that group he was one of the Giants in
this MIT history
of research between the brain and the
mind he had the unique culture unique he
was loved by everybody we all miss him a
lot
artificial intelligence started 50 years
ago about machine learning started
growing under the name of neural
networks about 25 years ago and academic
research in these two areas is one of
the main reasons for the emergence in
the last five years outside of
remarkably successful applications
commercial and not commercial like the
blue Google search Connect Watson mobile
I each of these systems computers that
play chess search the web recognize
human gestures inserted jeopardy allow
cars to see is at human level
performance in a narrow domain but none
of these systems can be said to be
intelligent these intelligence and the
problem of intelligence and of how the
brain produces intelligence and how to
make real intelligent machines is still
wide open so the main thesis to be
discussed in this symposium the way
George and I thought about it is that a
new effort in curiosity driven research
basic research is needed in order to
understand intelligence and understand
the brain that this new basic research
should this time not only rely on
computer science but also integrated
with neuroscience and cognitive science
and it should also integrate tightly
different aspects facets of intelligence
such as vision planning language social
intelligence so I believe that 50 years
later it is the time to try again this
symposium is a way to find out whether
we all agree that it is indeed time to
try again and if so how now I will
willing to start the real symposium and
I have the pleasure to introduce the
moderator of this extraordinary panel
Steve Pinker you all know Steve
so he does not need an introduction you
you all know him from his books starting
with a language instinct a great book
Steve was a colleague in my department
here at MIT and now we are loaning him
back for a few days from Harvard Steve
[Applause]
Thank You Tommy welcome to the golden
age look at the original roots of
artificial intelligence cognitive
science and neuroscience moderating this
panel is a daunting challenge that puts
me in mind of the famous quotation from
John F Kennedy when he hosted a dinner
at the White House for all of the living
Nobel laureates of the Western
Hemisphere he said this is the most
extraordinary collection of talent and
human knowledge that has ever been
gathered together at the White House
with the possible exception of when
Thomas Jefferson dined alone it's not
clear who the Thomas Jefferson figure
equivalent would be in this case
although I imagine there might be some
people in the audience who would
nominate our late colleague at the
inimitable Jerry laughs and the second
reason this is a daunting challenge is
that our distinguished panelists
represent a remarkable diversity of
interests from the biology of soil
roundworms
to the nature of logic truth and meaning
nonetheless I think there is a common
thread that all of them are contributors
to what I think of as one of the great
revolutions in human thought which is
the scientific understanding of life and
mind in terms of information computation
and feedback and control well into the
20th century life and mind remained
scientific mysteries life was thought of
as this mysterious substance called
protoplasm some kind of quivering gel
animated by an a la vie tau the mind was
thought of as a portion of some realm of
the soul or spirit or according to the
dogma of behaviorism something that
didn't exist at all just one big
category error but then in the middle
decades of the 20th century ideas of
thinkers like touring church von Neumann
Weiner Shannon Weaver McCulloch and
Pitt's gave us a rigorous language in
which to understand the concepts of
information and computation and apply
them to
masticate these formerly mysterious
realms in the process revolutionary
revolutionising biology and psychology
they gave us avenge what became the
insight that the stuff of life is not
some magical protoplasm but rather
matter that's organized by information
that and today when we discuss heredity
we use the language of linguistics we
talk about the genetic code we talk
about DNA sequences being synonymous or
meaningless or palindromic or stored in
libraries even the relation between
hereditary information and the actual
meat and juices of the organism we
explained with concepts from information
namely transcription and translation the
metaphor is profound
similarly the stuff of thought is no
longer thought to be some kind of
ghostly spirit nor Mirage or category
error but also can be understood in
terms of information that beliefs are a
kind of representation thinking a kind
of computation or transformation an
action a problem of control in the
engineer's sense these ideas we take for
granted now but I am always struck going
back to earlier great thinkers in
biology and psychology how much they
floundered without it if when one reads
great philosophers of mind like Hugh
Moore great biologists like Darwin I
often wish that I could reach back over
the centuries and tell them a few things
about the modern science of information
because one could see that they were
flailing around with hydraulic and
mechanical analogies that could be so
clearly explicate 'add by what we know
now about information and computation I
think it was the 1950s and early 1960s
that was a turning point in both fields
and the six people in today's panel were
all in different ways instrumental in
making it happen I don't think I'm going
to offend anyone's vanity by introducing
them and
inviting them to speak in order of age
sydney brenner is a biologist all of us
know that 58 years everyone knows that
58 years ago Watson and Crick explicate
the structure of DNA but the DNA is
would be useless if there wasn't some
way for the information that it
contained to actually affect the
development and functioning of the
organism the discovery of the genetic
code is something that we owe to our
first speaker Sydney Brenner working in
collaboration with Francis Crick and
others as if that weren't enough that
the discovery of the operation of the
genetic code and mechanisms of
translation into transcription into RNA
and translation into protein Sydney
Brenner was also instrumental in the
modern science of development how this
the information coded in the genes
actually builds a three-dimensional
functioning origin and for that matter
neuroscience both through his choice of
the lowly round word worm scenar of
Dittus elegans C elegans often known as
Sydney's worm which has exactly 959
cells 302 neurons and therefore offers a
perfect opportunity to reverse-engineer
the process of development and the
wiring of the nervous system in
recognition of this accomplishment
Sydney was awarded the 2002 Nobel Prize
in Physiology or medicine but perhaps an
even greater recognition is that he has
been immortalized in the Linnaean
taxonomy a sister species of C elegans
senior of Dittus Brenner I has been
named after Sydney Brenner Sydney is
senior distinguished fellow at the Crick
Jacobs Center at the Salk Institute for
Biological studies Marvin Minsky is a
computer scientist and he is widely
recognized as one of the founders
perhaps the founder of artificial
intelligence cognitive science and
robotics he
is responsible among other things for
the first neural network simulator the
first computer simulation of semantic
memory one of the first music
synthesizers first mechanical arm and
the first programmable logo turtle he is
since then been a major theoretician on
how to apply the computational analysis
to problems such as vision reasoning
learning common-sense consciousness
emotion and so on he has been recognized
with the Association of computing
Machinery's touring prize as well as the
Japan prize but perhaps most
significantly he was inspired arthur c
clarke when he was writing 2001 a space
odyssey and served as consultant for
that movie in particular for the
computer how Marvin Minsky is professor
of media arts and sciences emeritus at
MIT Noam Chomsky is a linguist who
revolutionized the study of language by
changing the very nature of the
questions that they field attempts to
answer Noam pointed out that the most
profound mystery of language is first of
all that any competent speaker can't
produce or comprehend an infinite number
of novel sentences therefore our
knowledge of language has to be captured
by a recursive generative system known
explored the mathematics of such systems
has developed a number of theories of
what kind of recursive generative system
is implemented in the human mind and
inspired the modern science of psycho
linguistics that explores how language
is processed in real time Noam also set
as a problem for linguistics the project
of figuring out how children acquire
first language without formal
instruction in an astonishingly short
period of time suggesting that children
are innately equipped with a universal
grammar of the abstract principles
behind language an idea that led to the
modern science of language acquisition
gnome is also largely responsible for
the over
of behaviorism as the main dogma in the
study of in psychology and philosophy
for rehabilitating the philosophical
approach of rationalism and for making
the concepts of an anus and modularity
respectable in the study of mind Chomsky
has been recognized among many prizes
with the Kyoto prize the Helmholtz medal
in the Ben Franklin medal he is also the
most cited living scholar
according to citation counts and has
become such a fixture of popular culture
that Woody Allen had him feature
prominently in his New Yorker story the
[ __ ] of Mensa and I believe that Nome
is the only MIT professor whose lecture
has ever been featured on the B side of
an album by the rock group Chumbawamba
no MS Institute professor emeritus in
the Department of linguistics and
philosophy here at MIT
Emilio beatsie is a neuroscientist who
made early contributions to our
understanding of sleep but has spent
most of his career studying the process
of movement Emilio is responsible for
setting the agenda for the neuroscience
of movement pointing out that the
movement of animals is not simply a set
of knee jerks or pressing a button and a
lever moving but rather has
goal-directed Nastase imple muscle
motion would be useless if it was
executed the same way regardless of the
starting position of the body and rather
that movements have to be organized
towards positions in space movement is
therefore an intelligent process at
every level of the neurosis of the
nervous system Emilio was also largely
responsible for the maturation of
neuroscience as a field which did not
even exist as a as a name when he
entered the field and was the founding
director of the Whitaker College of at
MIT and found in head of the department
of brain and cognitive sciences in which
I was privileged to teach for many years
in addition to his scientific brilliance
Emilio is widely respect
did as a man of judgment and airy
Edition and his wisdom has been tapped
in many scholarly organizations together
with prizes such as the empirical ease
prize and the president of Italy gold
medal for achievements in science price
me Leo has served as the president of
the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences Emilio is currently Institute
professor of neuroscience here at MIT
Barbara party is a linguist she was a
student in the first class of the fabled
MIT program in graduate program in
linguistics and as the first recipient
of a National Science Foundation
fellowship in linguistics her graduate
career symbolically inaugurates the
appearance of linguistics as a official
science Barbara
transformed the field of linguistics
which hitherto had concentrated on
syntax and phonology by putting
semantics the study of meaning on a
formal rigorous foundation tying
linguistics to the world of logic and
the concepts of meaning and truth she
remains the world's foremost Samantha
cyst and moreover trained all of the
world's other foremost Samantha cysts
when she retired recently her students
presented her with a genealogical tree
of all of the people that she has
trained it has they noted that it has a
depth of four which it means that she
has trained several great-great-grand
students and it has 176 nodes
Barbara has been recognized with the Max
Planck research award for the Max Planck
Society and is currently distinguished
University professor emeritus that's
feminine for emeritus at the University
of Massachusetts at Amherst I like
Patrick Winston is a computer scientist
he was one of the first researchers to
give a rigorous analysis of the concept
of learning in the framework of modern
symbolic artificial intelligence and his
work on the concept of learning
continues to be influential today he was
also instrumental in transforming
artificial intelligence from a bunch of
hackers in plaid flannel shirts to a
respectable academic field through his
his textbook for through directing the
artificial intelligence laboratory at
MIT for most of its existence and his
famous course in artificial intelligence
as well as starting a number of
companies patrick has been recognized by
a number of teaching awards including
the McVicker the baker and the graduate
student council award here at MIT and is
widely known and beloved aside from his
contributions to artificial intelligence
in his training of teachers through his
famous I ap talk how to speak which has
influenced many of us among the many
suggestions for how to keep a class
engaged he suggested that every lecturer
should cultivate some eccentricity
whether it be wearing a rope belt or
tugging a lock of your hair or racing
the blackboard with both hands I was
influenced by this as a postdoc and ever
since I have always lectured wearing a
gaudy necktie
Patrick is Ford professor of artificial
intelligence and computer science at MIT
I have asked the six panelists to spend
ten minutes each
sharing any personal thoughts that they
think the audience would enjoy on the
birth of the modern sciences of life and
mind and their reflections on the
origins key questions key discoveries
and open challenges of your field so
we'll start with Sydney I'd like to ask
each of you to support to speak for
about 10 minutes and then I will ask you
to amplify reflect acts ask each other
questions and so on I'll put a little
timer here to just remind you how much
time has elapsed
I've shrunk in recent years well I
thought I'd give to explain why I'm here
I thought I'd give two classes of
reasons the first will be sentimental
and I'd like to say that my association
with artificial intelligence has always
been as an interested spectator I don't
think I ever played in the game my
interest in it came from a very long
friendship with Seymour Papert we grew
up together in South Africa we shared
the rooms in department of physiology
I taught Seymour neurophysiology he
taught me mathematics and I came to the
conclusion he was both the better
student and the better teacher
it was the connection with Seymour that
when I finally grew up that brought me
into association with the Department of
artificial intelligence and I sent one
of my best students here I wouldn't say
he was a student one of my best
colleagues here David Marr and so those
are the reasons why I've always been and
in later years which I ask you to ponder
on there was a great adventure here
producing something called a thinking
machine in fact there was a corporation
named after that and I suppose that's
what we're after we have to resuscitate
sinking machines now I'd like to give
you the mental reasons why I'm here I'm
very influenced
1950-51 at was reading an article by
john von neumann called the theory of
self reproducing machines it had been
published in a book called the Hickson
symposium of cerebral mechanisms and
it's very interesting book to read
through because you can see all the
false leads that paper for Neyman went
unattended to that's the actual basic
logical construct for the way the way
the genes work and in fact the whole of
this is done without any reference to
biology and indeed when the biologists
discovered that this was the machinery
then nobody had mentioned for Neyman in
fact they all paid very great respect to
shredding shredding I wrote a book
called Watson's life everybody claimed
to read it I read it I didn't understand
so it had no influence on me but in
thinking back on it some years ago I
came to the conclusion that Schrodinger
had made a fundamental mistake
he said the genes contained the program
for development as we would put it this
day and the means to execute what for
Neyman said they don't contain the means
of execution
they contain the description of the
means of execution in other words you
can't the program is not self reading
you have to build a reader for it and
that's of course what fun no mountains
can and without this you can't make you
can't make a self reproducing machine
because it has to transmit to the next
machine a description of the means
to do it and I think that this is the
fundamental thing that lies behind us
and so if you like if you want to say
I've got this I've got this text in DNA
so long sequence can we read it can I
look in there and say yes that's a zebra
and it's going to be able to do these
things and that is if we believe in what
we can do so when you take this and you
try to analyze the difference it
analyzed the relationship between what
we inherit and what and how we can
perform and the big argument at the time
there's a connection between genes on
behavior which gave rise to a whole lot
of other problems such as saying that
intelligence is is something that is
inherited with the genome those are not
the questions really to ask because I
think you must divide the problem into
two as indeed it is divided in to do in
four Newman's view of it the first thing
is how does how do the genes specify and
build a machine that performs the
behavior and how does that machine
perform the behavior that is a separate
question of course the two are connected
as indeed they are but they must be
distinguished because what we're asking
is if we're looking at the behavior the
behavior is represented in the genome as
a description of how to build a machine
that behaves right and you see this is
very important to get that through
because the deepest problem is how did
all of this evolve because you can only
change the description
alright so there are very interesting
questions that are attached to this and
in following this line of thought I
thought that the only way to give a
scientific theory of a nervous system is
to ask how does the wiring diagram if I
can call it that
computer behavior because if we know how
how this is done we can look at the
deeper computation later which is how is
the script translated into what into the
machinery that builds this and in fact I
think a lot of science will now go to
what I call the forward question which
is how do we connect the output of a
system with its wiring diagram which is
the thing I think we have to solve but
of course this is a grand thing and one
of the things you learn is that there is
a difference between vision and eye
sight
I learned this by describing a friend of
mine as a man of great vision but poor
eye sight so we have to have good
eyesight to implement anything like this
and that is the story of the worm the
worm has 302 neurons seemed to me it was
a finite problem we could come to the
end of description and then after that
we had to we could deal with the
questions or that everybody raises when
you do modeling which is the skeptic who
stands there and say how do you know
there's not another wire that's thought
in the big tile runs up at the back and
connects this with us you have to be
able to say we know all the wires then
you can proceed so this was then to get
a total analysis of the structure of the
nervous system the struck
of the brain of the one 302 neurons
which we finally accomplished took 20
years because we had many many other
romances with computers in between we
tried to mechanize this but to do this
in the 1960s was impossible nowadays
that can be done and there's huge
activity now in getting these wiring
diagrams specified in my opinion
sometimes overzealously applied because
it's not going to answer the question
that we wanted to answer if I take a
worm of exactly the same genetic
structure will I find exactly the same
wiring diagram today you could ask sure
I've just cut a section of the spouses
brain and I found these sign Epps's and
you say well maybe if you delayed your
knife a half an hour would you film the
same sign abscess and indeed if you go
to another Mouse and look at the same
cell is it going to be the same that
however so I think that in approaching
this question I think that we are on the
threshold of really asking very serious
questions both in biology and in
relationship to the behavior of complex
systems and that's why I think this
initiative is very very important at the
time important to do now because I think
we'll have to take a completely
different approach to this in the future
as you know as you well know my
colleague Francis Crick got interested
in consciousness at one stage and I was
asked some time ago what did I think of
conscious
as a problem the great physicists Vigna
thought that consciousness would be the
explanation as why you can't predict
anything with quantum mechanics that
there would be this added ingredient my
view is this I think consciousness will
never be solved but will disappear now
50 years from now people will look back
and say what do they think they were
talking about here right I'll tell you
one other thing that has the same thing
and has disappeared
it is a thing called embryological
determination we had many discussions in
the 50s and 60s is determination
different from differentiation are they
different processes
nobody talks that way anymore because we
have a completely different view
different view of this and this is the
what I would like to say is going to be
changing those views changing many of
the other views of which I am NOT good
to talk about but I tell you the one
view that I would like to see very much
changed and that is the view of what a
gene stands for and in doing this I will
just deliver her a little parable to in
my sermon it was said that when we
sequence the human genome and we
sequence the chimpanzee genome we will
find one extra gene in the human that'll
be the gene for language and we'll call
it the Chomsky gene
if there's an alternative explanation
which is during their evolution
chimpanzees discovered talking gets you
into trouble
and so they evolved a language
suppressor gene then we'll call it the
Chomsky gene thank you very much
[Applause]
Marvin
I have too many notes when Brenner
started working on his worm C elegans
that was a big project 1960 was it and
to map out the nervous system of this
animal as well as the rest of it you had
to make very small slices with a
microtome and trace the nerves and other
organs in every layer and that's a
tremendous amount of work to do by hand
and he had employees for graduate
students I don't know what and this
process was taking a long time at the
same time McCarthy and I had started the
artificial intelligence group here and
had done a lot of work on computer
vision even by 1960 so I visited Brenner
and suggested that he should import a
couple of our graduate students who
would automate the process of vision and
Brenner said no and I said why and he
said well both of our fields are in
their very early stages and I have these
budding genetics biologists or whatever
and you have these budding computer
experts and if you let any of them into
my lab all of my students will realize
that your subject is much more exciting
and easier
do you remember that and it took me a
while to realize he was absolutely right
I don't know where to start
I love MIT and I've been here since in a
sense since 1957 because I started at
Harvard as an undergraduate and I could
talk about that for two days but in the
course of and then I went to graduate
school at Princeton and I'm not sure
where I'm going with this but every time
I've got interested in doing something I
was incredibly lucky I never had to do
any real work if I had a mathematics
problem well when I was a sophomore at
Harvard I sat down at a table with a
young man named Andrew Gleason who had
won the Putnam first prize in the Putnam
mathematical competition three or maybe
four years in a row which sort of
excluded everyone else in the world and
I asked what he was doing and he said he
was trying to solve Hilbert's fifth
problem which is that every continuous
every locally continuous group I forget
what it is anyway Oh every continuous
group is differentiable it's a very nice
problem and I said how long do you think
it will take to solve that and he said
nine years I had never met anyone with
with a plan of that magnitude
only a few years older than me and I
asked what that was and he said well
first I'll have to do Dedekind cuts to
show that the thing has to have real
numbers and blah blah blah anyway it
took him eight years and I think somehow
I was very early in my research career
and it seems to me that eight years was
plausible let's do things in anyway I
was just very lucky I ran into von
Neumann at some point when I was doing
my thesis at Princeton which was on
neural networks and I got the idea of
doing that from earlier work by
McCulloch and lots of people in the
1940s who it turned out that in 1895
Sigmund Freud had written a little paper
on neural networks but no one would
publish it and it wasn't published till
- around 1950 well I guess the same
question came up because I was in the
math department at Princeton and they
asked von Neumann is this PhD thesis
mathematics and I'm happy to say that he
replied if it isn't now it soon will be
and anyway there was something great
about the era and it's it's hard to talk
about how things started because it was
so different from it is today C 1950 is
shortly after World War two and the
country was very prosperous and there
were lots of research institutions
because there were a lot of monopolies I
mean a company like General Electric or
Westinghouse or even CBS were pretty
huge and they said Bell Laboratories of
course was a monopoly the others only
acted like it and so they would start
out different projects and one I guess
John McCarthy and I in the summer of
1950
one or two anyway we were we got summer
jobs at Bell Labs and someone told us
not to work on any problem that would
take less than 30 years they didn't have
the tenure deadline either now to get
tenure you have to be quick because
legally I think it 10 year is seven
years but they like it to be six years
because you don't want to keep people
hanging and what's more if you fire
somebody before that you have to pay
about a year termination fee and oh well
blah blah so it's very hard to get a
research grant for five years which was
sort of the standard that NIH and many
of these laboratories had so any
questions anyway we started this
artificial intelligence laboratory and
the first few I'll just stop in the
middle of the sentence when when time is
up because I never make plans I could
talk what oh oh it's an iPhone
I have one - baby anyway how did all
this happen when I was a child there
were a lot of books in the house and I
got interested in reading them and it
seemed to me that they fell into two
classes one was fiction and that was
novels does the joke I've made many
times and I read a few novels and it
seemed to me that they were all the same
even by great writers from Shakespeare
on down and there are about the six or
seven sins or the major ways that people
screw up their lives and so it typical
piece of fiction describes a situation
where something goes wrong and you try
to fix it and then something else goes
wrong and then this goes on until
finally you cure them all or you die it
doesn't make much difference so that's
what that's what general literature is
about and science fiction is about
everything else so somehow Isaac Asimov
lived nearby when he had just finished
and I just as I ran out of the Jules
Verne and HG Wells and Aldous Huxley and
the earth John Campbell and the early
science fiction writers exactly the
right people started to turn up which
was Robert Heinlein and 1942 I guess and
Isaac asked him off a little later and
Frederick Poe and I met Isaac because he
lived in Newton which is nearby and at
this time or somewhat later anyway we
were building the first robots
pretty much the although a guy named
grey Walter neurologist in West of
England had made some interesting ones
and I invited asked him off to come and
see our robots and he refused and this
happened a few times and finally I said
why not and he said I'm imagining really
intelligent robots of the future and if
I came and I'm sure that your robots are
really stupid which they were they could
they could play a very slow game of ping
pong and a few things like that you
might wonder why aren't there any robots
that you can send in to fix the Japanese
reactor that's broken reactors I should
say the answer is that for the last
there was a lot of progress in robotics
in the 1960s and 70s then something went
wrong if you go to Carnegie Mellon or I
don't want to mention names or or or
anywhere else you'll find students are
slaving over robots that play basketball
or soccer or a dance or make funny faces
at you and they're not making them
smarter
they don't use or don't realize that
they need something like artificial
intelligence so I'd like to see a return
back to the old days Brennan mentioned
consciousness I think and I agree
entirely that it's a very bad word
because if you look at my recent book
which is badly named the emotion machine
it says notice that people use the word
consciousness for 35 diff very different
things like remembering what you've
recently done
or making certain kinds of choices or
reacting to certain stimuli and so forth
and so virtually everything we don't
understand about the minds when people
do things is attributed to this word so
anyway that's that's one of the problems
and yet I see that professional people
in various Sciences still is the
distinction between conscious and not
and as far as I can see you can't get
rid of that word be what's its main use
its main use is deciding when someone is
a criminal if they run over you by
accident well that's very bad and you
might lose your license if you run over
someone in purpose that's intentional
conscious blah blah blah and so we have
the strange situation in psychology that
I don't see in other sciences which is
to use words that have been around for a
long time without I'm down on the 10% of
my notes so
[Applause]
Thank You Noam Chomsky well I kind of
like that idea of the language
suppressor gene it actually has a
venerable history which maybe you know
in the 17th century when Westerners were
discovering all kind of exotic creatures
like Apes and blacks and others and they
weren't sure what which was which there
was a lot of discussion about whether
ape orangutangs and apes could can speak
and they didn't seem to and there was a
lot of debate about why they didn't and
there was a proposal that there was they
didn't call it genes in those days but
there was the analog of a language
suppressor gene Louie Racine was the son
of the famous dramatist suggested that
Apes are really more intelligent than
humans and the proof of it is that they
don't speak because they knew that if
they did speak we would enslave them so
they keep quiet
this incidentally led to the conclusion
that a brilliant father can't have a
brilliant son I was I was in aural a
building 20 in the Golden Age and it
actually was a golden age but I got here
in 1955 the that was a quite an exciting
place a lot of enthusiasm innovation a
very lively interaction among people of
what widely different fields it's a kind
of community which I think will be very
hard if even possible to reconstruct I
also have many very warm memories of it
in fact some of them very hot memories
those of you who were around in those
days may remember that over the summer
the building 20 was unbearably hot you
could barely survive Mars Hallie and I
then shared a small office and we we
decided we would try to get the
Institute to put in a air conditioner
and window air conditioner so we sent a
message up through the bureaucracy and
it finally reached whatever high office
it got to and something came back down
to us finally with a message saying you
can't put in an air air conditioner
because it wouldn't be consistent with
the decor of building 20 those of you've
ever seen a picture of building 20 with
know what this meant
fortunately we could find the friendly
janitor who for 10 dollars was willing
to break the rules
he'll survive the summer back a few
years earlier in fact going back to the
time of the famous paper of Alan
Turing's paper on machine intelligence
in 1950 early 50s there was a small
group of graduate students and down the
road who were dissatisfied with
prevailing conceptions of how to
understand thought behavior or language
and so on and we were trying to see if
we can construct another way of looking
at these topics which could be might be
more promising and indict integrate
integrated better into the general
sciences and Turing's comments had a
certain resonance you may recall that in
this paper he which is about machine
intelligence he begins by saying that
the question whether machines can think
is too meaningless to deserve discussion
he didn't explain why but he presumably
meant that it's a question of what kind
of metaphor you are willing to accept so
it's like asking the airplanes really
fly or the submarines really swim if you
want to extend the metaphor yah I've not
no buts not a factual question he
nevertheless went on to say that it
would be a very good idea to construct
hard problems to see if you can design
machines meaning hardware and software
to solve them and the famous proposal of
his was what he called his imitation
game later came to be called the Turing
test
he thought that might be an incentive to
develop better machines better software
and for that reason it's good to do it
but we're not asking the machines think
he also suggested that maybe in the
course of time he said 50 years people
will come to because of this work people
to think about thinking in a different
way you can ask whether that's happened
the the machines it certainly was an
incentive to develop better machines and
that had a certain analogy to the kinds
of things we were concerned with there
is a for one thing because when you when
you look at language seriously wasn't
really done at that time unfortunately
we you can see right off that it's what
what each of us has internalized is some
kind of computational system a system
which in fact determines a an unbounded
array of structured expressions each of
which has dual interpretation its
interpreted by the sensory motor system
as some kind of externalization sound or
we now know other modalities and it's
interpreted at a internal roughly
speaking a kind of a thought system
called sometimes the conceptual
intentional system as having a
particular specific meaning which then
enters into planning of action and so on
so that's a computational system and the
constant understanding of computational
systems how advanced quite considerably
by the mid twentieth century in large
part because of Turing's work and that
sort of fit naturally also his provisos
made some sense for us there is a
standard question what counts as a
language and I think the Turing's
response was accurate
are the questions too meaningless to
deserve discussion for the same reasons
as machines thinking if you want to call
the communication systems of hundreds of
species of bees language okay you can
call it that that means you're accepting
a certain metaphor if you don't want to
call it that don't the fact it's not a
factual question the facts of the matter
are these systems differ radically every
animal
education system known that differs
radically in its basic principles and
structural principles of use others from
human language and human language is in
fact the earth different from Turing's
case it is in fact a particular
biological system one that each of us
has internalized that at its core
computational system with the kind of
properties that I mentioned and there's
no problem here about constructing hard
hard problems to deal with because it
was quickly discovered as soon as the
effort to construct such computational
systems was undertaken that almost
nothing was understood everything you
looked at was a puzzle and the more you
learn the more puzzles you discover that
was kind of surprising at the time
because it was assumed the prevailing
conception was that everything was more
or less known there's darn any real
problems about language it's just a
matter of well famous the version was
van wine highly influential philosopher
and most influential whose picture was
that the language is just a collection
of sentences associated with one another
and with stimuli by the mechanism of
conditioned response so all there is to
do is just trace the individual cases of
histories of conditions response and you
get the answers among linguists it was
very widely assumed that languages can
differ in any virtually any possible way
with virtually no constraints and the
only problem in linguistics I remember
this is a student there was to collect
more data from wider variety of
languages and applied to them the
techniques of analysis which were
assumed to be more or less understood
and that's the field but nothing could
be puzzling on the other end as soon as
the effort was undertaken to construct
an actual computational system with the
properties that I mentioned
it was discovered that everything is a
puzzle nothing is understood and some of
the poses are quite simple and some of
them are still outstanding in fact so
just to be concrete that take the simple
sentence it can evils that fly swim okay
we understand that it means we're asking
a question about whether they can swim
we're not asking a question about where
they can fly but that's a puzzle
why doesn't B can relate to the closest
verb why does it relate to the more
remote for one which in fact is closest
in a different sense it structurally
closes so similarly we can say our
Eagles that fly swimming but we can't
say our Eagles that flying swim now
that's a reasonable thought it's asking
is it the case that Eagles that are
flying swim but somehow we can't say it
the design of language prevents us from
articulating a perfectly fine thought
except by paraphrases and there is a
question why that should be true from a
computational point of view counting the
computing the closest verb computing
linear order and linear closeness is far
simpler than computing structural
closeness which requires complex
assumptions about the structure of the
object so there's a puzzle and the
puzzle have been around for thousands of
years except nobody thought it was a
puzzle
it's one of nurullah many such cases I
shouldn't mention that last couple of
years this or even substantial industry
has developed to try to deal with it on
computational grounds and we'll talk
about that I don't think it gets
anywhere but it's a real puzzle and
furthermore that principle of using
structural distance but not linear
distance
is all over the place you find it in
structure after structure in all
languages and it seems to just be some
universal property of language and a
very puzzling one
well discoveries that kind are kind of
reminiscent of the earliest moments of
modern science go back to say 1600 for
thousands of years scientists had been
quite satisfied with an explanation for
such things as why stones fall down and
steam goes up they're seeking their
natural place into that story when
Galileo and a few others allowed
themselves to be puzzled about that you
start getting modern science and I think
that continues the capacity to be
puzzled about what looks sort of obvious
is a good it's a good property to
cultivate and that it's an awakening and
that began at that time and it turns out
there's there's enormous linguistic
evidence that this is the way things
work there's also in recent years some
evidence from the neurosciences there's
some interesting investigations being
carried out by a very good group at
Milan the linguist in the group under
Amoros well-known here he's been here
many times they've been investigating in
the reaction of people to two types of
stimuli one all new to them rural
systems that meet the conditions the
basic conditions of what's called
universal grammar of the general
principles of language and others that
violate these conditions and use things
like linear order so for example an
invented language in which it's a form
to negate a sentence you take the
negative word and you put it in a third
position in the sentence let's say it
turns out that brain activity is quite
different in these cases in the case of
a normal language which the people of
never been
to Broca's area language areas are
activated in the normal way but in a
case of linear order it's not these
language areas don't have the normal
activation that people may figure it out
but they're figuring it out as some kind
of puzzle to solve not using their
linguistic capacities well you know all
of this oughta be puzzling and it is and
in fact as far as I know the only
serious proposal as to how to explain it
has pretty far-reaching conclusions a
the natural assumption is that at the
point at which the computations are
taking place in the brain there just is
no order there's no ordering at all all
there is is hierarchy so the only thing
the brain can compute is a minimal
structural distance because there's no
no linear order well that looks pretty
plausible in fact for many points of
view but one reason is that if you look
at the syntax and semantics of language
for a very broad or class of cases order
doesn't matter what matters is hierarchy
now furthermore if you look at the sit
so that would suggests that one of those
two interfaces the semantic interface
with the thought system just doesn't
care about order on the other hand the
sensory motor system must have some kind
of arrangement depending on what the
form of the externalization is if it's
speech it will be then your orders it's
sign it'll be various things in parallel
but it has to have some kind of ordering
so it's reasonable to suppose that the
ordering is simply a reflex of the
externalization but doesn't enter into
the core properties of language which
simply give you the thought the what's
used in the thought system that
effectively means if
correct and it seems to be that in the
you know informal sense of the term
design you know the designer but in the
formal sense of the term design
languages designs for thought and not
for externalization externalization is a
ancillary process and that would mean
incidentally that communication which is
just a special case of externalization
is an even more ancillary process
contrary to what's widely believed that
has significant implications for the
study of evolution of language we'll go
into them that you can think of through
and for the nature of design of language
well there are other kinds of evidence
that have similar that leads similar
conclusions says a lot about the
architecture of mine if this is correct
for example one class of cases is this
kind of a ubiquitous phenomena and
language of sometimes called
displacement you hear something in one
position but you've interpreted
somewhere else so if you say what did
John see you have to interpret the word
what in two positions where it is where
it's kind of an operator asking telling
you asking some question about what
person or something like that and also
in another position as the object of C
just as in John saw you know the book or
something where it's getting its
semantic role as the object of the verb
it's got to be interpreted in those
positions it's as if the mind is hearing
something like for which thing X John
saw X where the for which thing is an
operator ranging over the variable that
shows up in other ways that unpronounce
tellement turns out to really be there
for the mental processes that are taking
place you can see that in sentences like
say
they expect to see each other we're the
phrase each other is referring back to
they say the man expect to see each
other on the other hand if you had if
you had a another noun in between in the
right position it wouldn't work so if
say the men expect Mary to see each
other then that somehow breaks it up
each other can't go back to the man well
what about who does the men expect to
see each other well that's like the men
expect John to see each other each other
doesn't go back to the man but there's
nothing there in the form that you hear
is it's just like they expect the men
expect to see each other well that
suggests strongly that the mind is
actually hearing interpreting for which
a person acts the men expect X to see
each other and that X is like John when
you pronounce it and things like that
can get pretty complicated so if you
take a sentence like say they expect
they think that every artist likes one
of his pictures best like maybe the
first one he painted if you take one of
his pictures and you ask a question
about it so which one of his pictures do
they expect every artist to like the
best the answer would be well his first
one even though which of his pictures is
not in the right position to be bound by
the quantifier that every and that
becomes clearer if you make a different
question suppose you say which of his
pictures convinced the museum that every
artist paints flowers well there's no
relation we never in his there that
would structurally think it through
about the same as the one that works was
really only one plausible interpretation
for that and that is that the phrase
which of his pictures is actually
appearing twice it's appearing
getting its semantic role as the object
of like and it's appearing where it is
being interpreted as an operator ranging
over the variable
well that and these these examples
proliferate into pretty complicated
cases when you look at them closely
turns out interestingly that all of this
follows if you develop an optimal
computational system the one that has
that meets the condition of perfect
computational efficiency as the least
possible computational operations then
it turns out that what goes to the right
to the mind ought to have all these
copies they don't get erased on the
other hand what goes to the mouth has
Amol erased except for one tell you that
it's there that turns out to be optimal
computation but that has a consequence
it means that optimal computation the
core of language design is oriented
towards the meaning the mapping to the
you know the transformation changed what
comes out of the mouth is causing
communicative difficulties anyone who's
ever worked on a parsing program you
know trying to figure out how to
mechanically interpret what a sentence
structure and meaning of a sentence
knows that one of the hardest problems
is what's called filler gap problems you
hear the word watt at the beginning of
the sentence and you got to find where
is the gap the unpronounce
element that this what is related to if
you pronounce them all that wouldn't be
a problem you'd most most of the cases
would be solved but efficient
computation leads to the consequence
that it undermines communicative
efficiency that's pretty much like the
case of our Eagles that flying's count
Eagles are Eagles of flying swim nice
thought that you can't say
again optimal operation of the
operations is leading to communicative
difficulties and quite generally as an
interesting class of cases known now
where you have conflicts between
communicative computational efficiency
and communicative efficiency and
computational efficiency wins hands down
in every case that's understood which
again suggests that the design of
language is really for for meaning it's
for semantics and intentional
interpretation now to organized speech
acts and so on and that the
externalization of it the the fact that
it sort of computers in the outside
world somehow is just an X second Airy
process communication and tertiary
processes well that reorients our
conception about how the mind works but
it looks pretty plausible well another
issue kind of is along the curve a keep
going back to the 50s it was of course I
understood right away that none of this
can it's impossible for any of these
things to be learned by association
conditioning induction any simple
mechanism so it must be the case that
these examples of the kind that I
mentioned are which are known very early
by children little evidence they must
result from the other two possible
factors in development one of them is
some genetic endowment which is a
species property apparently all humans
share essentially the same endowment no
difference is known so that's one and
the other is just laws of nature you
know the kinds of laws that determine
say that a cell divides into spheres not
cubes though genetics involved some but
not much the the interaction of these
two factors ought to be able to yield
results of this kind
there's a fair amount of evidence
supporting that the kinds of things I
mentioned Illustrated of course
languages differ all over the place that
was none - so you have to show that
these principles that you're postulating
are going to apply universally that does
not mean contrary to a wide widely held
misunderstanding that you can read in
journals like nature and science and
others it does not mean that they're
going to be descriptive generalizations
about language that hold universally in
fact it might turn out there's no
descriptive generalizations at all and
you have a very rich genetic structure
it's not the case but it could turn out
because the things that you see are
reflections of internal processes that
are going on that meet other conditions
like efficient computation but it must
be somehow you got to apply to
everything well in the 50s in the Golden
Age a few languages were studied the
ones that people knew and arly at that
time actually one of the first extensive
studies was on an American Indian
language hi that's it the first
dissertation in the department actually
it was in the EE Department because we
didn't have a formal department than it
was on Turkish it was of course working
on English Mars Holly was working on
Russian by the 1960s as the department
developed and people came in from all
over the range of languages investigated
expanded enormous Lee and the 80s and
the and since it's just exploded there's
no intensive investigation of languages
of a very wide tautological variety all
kinds of new problems being discovered
sometimes new answers sometimes they
lead to further problems and so on at
the same time the what Steve mentioned
before the study of language acquisition
really took off actually Steve's
work was part of the early work on this
in the 80s that based on trying to
discover
the options of variation of language
which is all that has to be picked up by
a child the rest is fixed how those are
set on the basis of data and find out
quite a lot of work on that all of this
is finished by saying the plenty of
problems remain I don't want to
overstate but there's some fairly
striking and reasonably plausible
conclusions which far-reaching
implications all of this however is
restricted to what's going on inside the
internal computing system what's going
on inside the mine now somehow language
has to be related to the outside world
and because there are two interfaces
it's going to have to be related in two
different ways
at the sensorimotor interface the
question is hard but sort of understood
that's the topic of acoustic and
articulatory phonetics which has been
studied pretty intensively orally to for
sixty years and a lot of results a lot
of problems but at least the problem is
trying to in hand but what about the
other end how does the meaning side
relate to the outside world well there
is a doctrine that's widely held it's
supposed to give an answer to this it's
sometimes called a referential is
doctrine it holds that the elementary
semantic units let's say words for
simplicity they relate to the outside
world
by a relation of reference picking
something out or denotation for
predicate speaking out a class of things
so like how the word cow picks out cows
were cows or something that a physicists
could identify in principle the only
problem and that's very widely held it
was known but in classical Greece that
that's not correct you know much of a
deep analysis but examples showing it
doesn't work in the 17th century and the
we ought to call the first cognitive
revolution many of the questions
significant questions were raised still
puzzling today it was widely understood
that that doesn't work that the assumed
David Hume put it summarizing a century
of inquiry that the way we categorize
things the things we categorize that are
fictitious created by the mind using
your stock properties notions of cause
and effect the notions of psychic
continuity for sentient objects John
Locke studied this and other properties
that a physicist cannot identify they're
imposed by the mind on flux of
experience and those are the entities if
you like sort of mental entities that we
construct and they're somehow related to
the world
well this poses a huge problem there's
no animal communication system known
that has anything remotely like this
they are the referential is doctrine
apparently holds so if you take say
cries of vervet monkey each cry is keen
to some identifiable physical event you
know like leaves are moving we interpret
that as meaning an Eagles coming all the
vertebrates run and hide I don't know
how they interpret is another question
but or else it's an internal sort of
hormonal phenomenon like I'm hungry or
something like that
every communication system it's known
works like that but human language
doesn't work like that at all there's a
you can't you take a look at the words
of the language and none of them work
like that and that's a real problem
that's for one thing it's a tremendous
evolutionary problem like where'd all
this come from totally unknown and maybe
unknowable but it's also a problem for
the nature of language and for the
acquisition of language like how did you
and find these properties which they get
to understand very quickly in fact
things like fairy children's fairy tales
exploit them effectively
well that's these are major mysteries
that remain on the horizon right at the
core of what language and thought are
about and there are plenty of other ones
so I just suggest again that the
capacity to be puzzled is a good one to
cultivate
[Applause]
thank you very much gnome Emilio beatsie
well one of the can you hear me
yep one of the goals of artificial
intelligence as I understand it was to
build intelligent machines and there's a
class of course of intelligence machines
that move like robots and so what what
I'm going to discuss is movement not in
machines but movement from a biological
perspective and then at the end I will
discuss the interaction between
artificial systems like robots and
biological system that move but for the
for the for the initial part of my
discussion here I like to point out
something that I can illustrate with an
example let's say when I want to reach
this pair of glasses well this is
something extremely simple we do it
hundreds of time per day we have done it
for thousands and thousands of times so
what's a big deal about it
well this simple gesture here points out
an important fact and that is that what
seems to be a very simple action in
reality the neural processes that
subserved
that make it makes it make it possible
for this action to be expressed of great
complexity and this complexity is to a
certain extent mysterious we know a
little bit about it we know we know that
some of the
some of the computations are beginning
to be seen but an enormous amount of
things that have to do with actions that
at this point remain fairly mysterious
so let me start with what we have
glimpsed recently in the last few years
and that has to do with them and I'll go
back to this example if I want to touch
this glass pair of glasses then I have
to do a number of things simultaneously
I have to move my eyes my eye muscles my
neck muscles my trunk muscles and of
course then there are muscles now from
anatomical point of view all these
muscles are made of elements which are
the muscle fibers and that each group of
muscle fibers receives a fiber from the
central nervous system and particularly
from in this case from the spinal cord
so what we have here is that to
implement this simple gesture the
central nervous system has to control in
enormous space an enormous number of
elements that is the muscle fibers that
make up the muscles so this this is in a
sense a gigantic problem because we have
an extremely tough computational problem
how to arrange this distribution of
signals to a very vast space well in the
last few years a number of investigators
have identified elements of the
architecture of the central nervous
system that deals with movement that has
indicated a modularity and this
modularity has been identified
dominantly in this panel chord it's also
maybe also in a upper part of the
brainstem but in any case most of it is
in the spinal cord and what it does it
means that there are groups of
interneurons that manage to put together
in a unit a group of muscles what does
that mean it means that the number of
degrees of freedom this bath space has
been reduced dramatically in such a way
that the descending fibers from the
cortex that convey from the brain down
to the spinal cord the information for
movement all they have to do is to
combine they activate these very various
modules in the spinal cord combine them
and provide coefficient of activations
for each one and this view of of how the
brain manages to be so effective in
producing movement is derived from
experimental work that in this labyrinth
in my laboratory and another laboratory
has been performed in the last ten years
now there are other things that are more
mysterious when I do the simple movement
here this movement is learned has been
learned somehow during the course of
life the site of learning motor learning
is certainly the motor cortex of the
brain so the frontal areas of the
frontal lobe now these areas of the
frontal lobe of course connected with
the subcortical nuclei with the
cerebellum and so on and certainly they
all these areas in conjunction with the
connectivity of the spinal cord
represent the circuitry that in
the signals the memory signals they are
necessary to do this simple action but
here is there is a catch when I do these
simple actions I can do them like in
front of you now but I can do it by
moving my body in a different posture I
can be reclining and nevertheless I can
accomplish the same goal so this is it's
a very tough to understand how the
signals have been memorized can be which
specify particular muscles that have to
be activated in that particular context
can in another context still be just as
effective so this is a question of
generalization and this we I don't
understand how the central nervous
system manages to do this process of
generalization so effectively there are
also other computational problem that
are quite quite difficult to to see how
they are implemented in the central
nervous system and that is I can reach
this pair of glasses if there is an
obstacle I can go up this way I can go
down this way so this is a pressure of
planning how better rates are extremely
good at planning they are actually
depending on on the environment and how
again this the memory that guides the
memory movements how can that be
translated into and the signals modified
in order to accomplish pathways that
each time potentially different it
depends on the environment now there are
other things that are less somewhat less
mysterious
we know that in among the vertebrates a
certain amount of learning goes through
by imitation and recently some light has
been shed on this process of learning by
mutation neurons have been found in the
frontal lobe that discharge when the
subject sees an action and when the
subject repeats that that action the
similar action so these are called
mirror neurons and they are an important
feature of the motor system that same
seem to provide the basis for for for
learning by imitation now although there
are all these tough computational
problems that need to be understood I am
optimistic that in the next few years we
will make a lot of progress and the
reason is that there are many
laboratories scattered in various parts
of the of the world that are pursuing
the issues of Robotics humanoid robotics
that is what they're trying to do is to
put these properties that I've described
to you generalization planning learning
by imitation and so in machines and I
don't know how far this effort how much
they these people have accomplished but
nevertheless the fact that there is this
intellectual attitude toward
implementing in machines they the
solutions try to find the computational
solutions that provide these properties
to machines is a way to really
understand it's a way to understand you
when you start to make things the
beginning
to face the computational problems and
understand there is also enough finishes
there is an also in a new field which is
which is a most promising and that is to
place sets of micro electrodes into the
brain of has been tried with humans and
is usually tried in animals and connect
the output of the signals that come out
of these micro electrodes and connected
with machines so this is a brain machine
interactions which obviously has
tremendous importance both in
understanding the the center de workings
of the central nervous system and also a
practical understanding their practical
significance in rehabilitation of
amputees and so on now for the time
being there are technical problems that
prevent the quick implementation of
brain machine interruptions and those
have to do with the brain reacts to the
contact with these permanent content
with these electrodes in the brain
essentially they are rejected after a
while but it's conceivable that when
more the different types of different
technologies could be used in order to
get around this problem so this is why
the two reasons why I have a certain
amount of optimism that for the future
this in in automatic intelligence will
be understood thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Emilio barber party for me the
adventure began just fifty years ago
here at MIT in 1961 the chomskyan
revolution had just begun and Noam
Chomsky and Morris Halle had just opened
up a ph.d program in linguistics and I
came in the first class I want to start
by thanking Chomsky and Halle for
building that program and I thank MIT
and the research laboratory of
electronics for supporting it I'm
indebted to Chomsky for revolutionising
the field of linguistics and making it
into a field whose excitement has never
waned Chomsky redefined linguistics as
the study of human linguistic competence
making linguistics one of the early
pillars of cognitive science at the
center of the chomskyan Revolution was
syntax generative grammar a finite
specification of the infinite set of
sentences of a language that launched an
extremely productive research program
but it didn't include semantics Chomsky
considered meaning scientifically
intractable and he wasn't alone when
linguist did soon tried to add semantics
to generative grammar there were two big
obstacles a lack of good formal tools
and the absence of any non subjective
notion of meaning it was the UCLA
logician Richard Montague who
revolutionized the study of semantics in
the late 1960s he built on successes in
formalizing the syntax and semantics of
logical languages the work of Fraga
tarski and others Montagu himself
developed a higher-order typed
intentional logic with a model theory
and with its help he was able to
formalize a significant part of the
syntax and semantics of English within a
clearly articulated theoretical
framework the result was what we now
call
formal semantics Eman Bach has summed up
Chomsky's and Montague's cumulative
innovations thus Chomsky showed that
English can be described as a formal
system Montagu showed that English can
be described as an interpreted formal
system for me as a young sin tactician
at UCLA in the late 60s Montague's work
was eye-opening linguists had been
building tree like semantic
representations okay for capturing
certain things like scope ambiguity but
otherwise leading to endless arguments
about competing representations we
linguists never dreamed of truths
conditions being relevant for
linguistics but Montague's work and
David Lewis's showed that crews truth
conditions are crucial for giving
semantics an on subjective foundation a
linguistically exciting part was that
was such a rich logic we could get a
close match between syntactic
constituents and semantic constituents
and meanings of sentences could be built
up recursively and compositionally from
the meanings of their parts of their
syntactic parts one brief illustration
Bertrand Russell had argued that natural
language syntax is logically very
misleading since it puts John and
everyman into the same syntactic
category of noun phrases where as in
first order logic John walks and every
man walks must have radically different
syntactic structures Montagu showed that
natural language syntax does not have to
be logically misleading at all all noun
phrases can be treated uniformly in
higher-order logic as so-called
generalised quantifiers and English
subject predicate sentences like John
walks and every man walks can then be
interpreted in a similar manner
straightforwardly generalized quantifier
theory is now one of many rich topics in
formal semantics and it can explain many
things that we couldn't explain with
just syntax
I started working on Montague grammar in
about 1970 to try to integrate it into
linguistics by finding ways to put
Chomsky's and Montague's work together
from the early 70s collaborative work
among philosophers logicians and
linguists in the US and Europe built in
many directions one important result is
that with a serious semantics to share
the load syntax doesn't have to do all
of the work that we once imagined
syntactic and semantic advances now
often develop in tandem each informing
the other by the late 1980s formal
semantics was well established with in
linguistics departments in the u.s. in
Europe it may be in linguistics or in
philosophy among middle generation
leaders of formal semantics I'll just
mention two who are involved in this
symposium and who were my PhD students
at UMass in the 1980s I Reina Haim head
of the department of linguistics and
philosophy here became mi t--'s first
formal semantics faculty member in 1989
and generic Erica is now head of
linguistics at Harvard both have made
seminal contributions that have helped
shape the field I have to mention one
seeming paradox which relates to open
challenges as well as to past progress I
stressed how the chomskyan revolution
made linguistics and early pillar of
cognitive science yet frege's anti
psychologists extense shared by Montagu
was crucial in the foundations of formal
semantics traiga argued that truth
conditions and not mental ideas have to
be at the core of the meaning of a
sentence and the work of generations of
linguists and philosophers has shown the
fruitfulness of that approach first we
have to formalize what the semantics of
our language is what our sentences say
about how the world is then figure out
how our knowledge of it such as it is is
acquired and exploited
this stance might seem to exclude formal
semantics from cognitive science but I
believe on the contrary it makes the
contributions of semantics to cognitive
science all the more interesting human
language is a remarkable achievement
part of what's remarkable is how we
implicitly recognize and navigate the
social construction of meaning when we
converse we simultaneously exchange
information and negotiate meaning David
Lewis's classic work on convention was
an early milestone in exploring the
relation between individual competence
what's in the head of one language user
and social intelligence an important
dimension that is still probably under
explored as for newer directions the
best understood parts of formal
semantics concern the semantic
compositions of parts from wholes no of
whole sorry of holes from parts of
course yeah this this the semantics of I
proofread this several times the what we
might call the semantics of syntax there
has also been great progress on
formalizing parts of pragmatics
involving the interaction of meaning
language use and context including the
study of how contexts both effects and
is affected by interpretation and
studies in language processing now
include formal semantics and pragmatics
and game theoretic approaches are having
a growing influence computational formal
semantics is now a subfield of
computational linguistics contributing
to both theoretical and applied goals
and there's promising early work on
universals and typology in semantics
with innovative field work uncovering
semantics and pragmatics subtleties of
various indigenous languages and just as
in syntax such languages proved to be as
semantically rich and complex as
familiar more familiar European
languages there are many challenges
facing formal semantics and its
relatives these are still young
I'll mention just two that I think are
important both for the field and for the
goals of this symposium first the
semantics of sentential structures is
increasingly well understood but lexical
semantics is really hard and formal
methods are weakest here it's in lexical
semantics that we most clearly cannot
equate the language with our knowledge
of it as Hilary Putnam observed years
ago the fact that he doesn't himself
know anything that would distinguish a
beech tree from an elm tree does not
mean that beech and elm are synonyms in
his language the lexicon has lots of
linguistically important sub structure
but it's also the part of language that
interface is most strongly with non
linguistic knowledge with encyclopedic
knowledge with our common sense ontology
with visual imagery with cultural
associations and on and on and connected
with that another challenge is how to
build formal semantics into real-time
processing models whether we think of
psychological models of how we do it or
computational models that might do it in
an applied way models that involve the
integration of linguistic and not
specifically linguistic knowledge this
concerns not only lexical semantics but
also all kinds of context dependence
implicit content meaning shifts and
non-literal uses of language I know
there is progress I'm not an expert in
those areas but I believe this is a
domain where major interdisciplinary
innovation and cooperation may be
crucial just an illustration of the
challenges I'm pretty sure that the most
successful search engines do not do any
formal semantic analysis of questions
that we ask or of texts that they are
searching I've heard of some beginnings
of some nice work in that direction but
large-scale all-purpose fast search
engines
or quote intelligent machines that
really know and use semantics as we
studied are probably still far in the
future I would and in conclusion I would
say I would suppose that really knowing
semantics is a prerequisite for any use
of language to be called intelligence so
if there's to be a new basic research
effort to understand intelligence and
the brain semantics is ready to
contribute to it and to gain from it
Thank You Barbara and Patrick Winston
that you're going to be a motel organism
as I recall what would you like to use
the podium I
I think I'll not use that I I've never
written very good at introductory
statements so I haven't prepared one
I'll ask myself a few questions instead
and my first question is well what do
you think so far and that's a difficult
question for me to answer because
several of the speakers you may have
noticed ran out of time I was
particularly disappointed that Marvin
was unable to give us a detailed account
of his assessment of the progress that's
been made in artificial intelligence in
the past 20 years so I decided to
dedicate a little of my time to doing a
simulation of Marvin
and here it is and that concludes my
simulation of Marvins account of the
past 20 years now it's certainly the
case that many people would contest the
view that there's been no progress but I
don't think anyone would contest the
view that there could have been more
progress in the past 20 years than there
has been and I think it's informative to
think about why that might be because we
have no lamp to guide us into the future
except the lamp of what is what is past
before and I think that in my view what
went wrong went wrong in the 80s and the
first thing that went wrong is that we
all discovered that artificial
intelligence technology was actually
useful and that led to a kind of
commercial distraction which from which
the field has never recovered so that's
one problem another problem of course is
that that happened to be the decade in
which the Cold War ended and as a
consequence of that there were shifts in
funding patterns that contributed to the
problem because sponsors were no longer
as interested in and be a mean princess
of science but rather became much more
interested in short-term goals
demonstrations and the like but I think
the most insidious problem was what I'd
like to label the mechanistic
balkanization of the fields what
happened in that period was that
artificial intelligence as a field
matured and began to break up into
communities that were coagulating around
mechanisms rather than problems so it
was in the 80s that we began to see
conference that's dedicated to neural
nets conferences dedicated to genetic
algorithms conference is dedicated to
probabilistic inference
and when you dedicate your conferences
to subjects of that kind to mechanisms
then there's a tendency to not work on
fundamental problems but rather those
problems that the mechanisms can
actually deal with this tended to affect
not only the conference's that were
being held but also the kind of jobs
that were offered by universities those
job descriptions tended to have phrases
in them like neural nets probabilistic
inference genetic algorithms and the
light I I think it was in about 1995
that I had a horrible nightmare
as a consequence of this I was on the on
the search committee for the electrical
engineering computer science department
at the time and and in my nightmare we
had put out a call for people interested
in making an application to work at MIT
as a professor in electrical engineering
and computer science department and
Jesus applied
and after due consideration of the
application we decided to send the
standard letter thank you for your
interest in our department we regret
that with over 400 applicants we cannot
interview anyone and besides this year
we're not looking for a theologian it
was because of that kind of
balkanization which focused everyone on
particular rather narrow elements of the
field so what to do some people say well
Winston the trouble with you is you're
just a hopeless romantic about the past
but that's not entirely true because I'm
also romantic about the future it's just
right now that may not be so hot and I
and I think the future is a it does
offer some some hope and you might say
why I think the reason is because we we
now are gradually becoming less stupid
about what to do
so you might say well what is it that
you think we should do and and then I
and then my response would be well I
think we should take the right approach
and then you would say what is the right
approach what do you call your approach
and I would reply well I call my
approach the right way and then you
might say well what does your approach
have to offer and then I would say that
my approach what my approach has to
offer is a focus on the fundamental
differences between our human species
and other primates and in particular to
other others of the homogeneous and you
might say well what are those properties
that separate us from for instance the
Neanderthals and who knows but if we
want a clue the best thing to do is to
ask people who study the question so
I've been much influenced by for example
the cultural rather the
paleoanthropologists in Tattersall who
says who tells us that we as a species
coexisted quite happily with the
Neanderthals for about a hundred
thousand years and during that time we
made approximately the same kind of
stone
tools and during that time there was
approximately no progress in our making
of stone tools but then about 60,000
years ago or so something magical
happened to the human species it
probably happened in southern Africa and
it probably happened in a neck down
population of maybe many hundred but
certainly not more than a few thousand
individuals and once we got that new
property it spread throughout the human
population and within ten thousand years
we had either wiped out or out competed
the Neanderthals wiped out a lot of
species along our path throughout the
world and never look back and so what is
it then that was that magic property
once again who knows what we can we can
speculate and I've heard gnomes say
things like it was the capacity perhaps
to take two concepts and put them
together to make a third concept and to
do that without limit and without
disturbing the concepts that got merged
together other that's probably right and
I would hazard to layer a piece on top
of that because I think that that
capability in turn makes it possible for
us to describe events and once we can
describe events its natural to develop a
capacity to string them together into
stories and once we have stories then we
can take two stories and blend them
together to make another story and once
we have that we have at least a kind of
creativity and once we have that we have
a species that's much like any much not
like much different from any other so
I've come to believe that that story
understanding is one of the great things
that's enabled by the inner language
that's underneath our communication
language and I think that the past fifty
thousand years has been a period of time
in which we have become increasingly
awash in stories we are soaked in
stories from our birth through our death
we start with fairy tales we continue on
through religious parables we've gone to
literature in history we end up perhaps
with law school or medical school and
throughout that whole period of
Education we are essentially
accumulating and learning to manipulate
the stories that come to us in our
culture and in our environment so that's
what I think ought to be done and now
you might ask a natural question what
kind of property do you need in order to
study this particular these are the
particular questions that derived from
this approach and the answer is that
there's only one property that you
really need and that is I think naive
optimism in the face of overwhelming
contraindication but that's okay I don't
mind that because at the very least I
think that through the study of stories
that we will develop at least sharper
questions to ask in the next generation
I also think it's possible to do the
kinds of things that I do better today
than I was able to do them some years
ago because I think I've gradually
become less stupid about the steps that
need to be taken in order to make
progress so here are the steps that I
think you need to take in order to make
progress first of all you need to
characterize the behavior next after you
characterize the behavior you need to
formulate a computational problem and
once you formulate a computational
problem then you could take step three
which is to propose a computational
solution and all of these things are the
natural objectives of classical
psychology but then there's a fourth
step what you have the proposed solution
to the computational problem then the
kind of thing that I do
I could I could refer to as exploratory
development building systems that you
believe will have the behavior that you
have characterized in virtue of the
computational solution that you have
proposed and whence you and and and when
you do that you discover to your horror
and amazement that you've left things
out that your solution is incomplete and
you have to go back through that cycle
again and again
and again so I think that's four steps
the computational problem rather the the
behavior the computational problem with
all the constraint necessary to solve it
a proposed solution exploratory
development and is one of my students
leonid fedorov mentioned to me this
morning that isn't enough either because
at step four you might be at the same
situation that the Romans were when they
had catapults you can improve them we
didn't understand them until you had a
notion of Newtonian mechanics so the
fifth step then is you have to look back
over the first four steps and
crystallize out the principles that made
everything possible so that's what I
think ought to be done and that's what
the sort of thing that I do but as I say
that I think it would be easy to suppose
that I think everything happens in
symbol land merely because we are
symbolic species but I don't think
everything happens in symbol land
because I think we make use of the stuff
that was there before in particular we
have to solve a lot of problems with our
perceptual apparatus so I could say for
example to you
Sebastian kissed Aaron and then I could
ask did Sebastian touch Aaron and you
would immediately reply yes of course
because you can imagine it and you don't
you don't feel like you're doing
syllogistic reasoning you feel like
you're imagining the situation and I'm
reading the answer off of your imagined
you the imagination the imagined
situation with your perceptual apparatus
and I think that's right I think we know
a lot of things latent ly and we don't
have to be told them we don't have to be
told that if you kiss somebody you touch
them because we can figure that out on
the fly and then of course we can cache
it in our symbolic systems if we want
but the point is that we can compute
that stuff when we need it so we know
vastly more than we actually know here's
another example that I I'm very fond of
I borrowed it from Shimon Ullman
it's the example of well what am i doing
it's not a trick question I'm drinking
now what am i doing I'm toasting now
what am i doing I'm admiring this fine
davit a fuii glass but then for the next
example I have to ask you to exercise
your own power of imagination because I
don't have a slide that does it what I
want to imagine is that I'm a cat and my
mouth has pointed to the sky and up
there above my mouth is a leaking faucet
what am i doing I'm drinking even though
that kind of drinking doesn't look
visually anything like the kind of
drinking I did with my first example yet
somehow we label those both is drinking
so my view is that it must be the case
that this kind of drinking and that kind
of drinking is telling the same story
that there's a story about thirst that
there's story about motion there's a
story about liquid and moving movement
through space into your mouth and that's
the story of drinking and you can
recognize it from a single frame as a
drinking story even though it's very
different from other from other frames
of other video so you've seen that tell
the the drinking story so that's what I
think and the last question I'll ask
myself is what I've tried to contribute
here today and the answer is I tried to
talk a little bit about why I think we
haven't made progress in the field this
to the extent that we should have what I
think we ought to do now in order to
make progress and the steps that I think
need to be taken by people who are
trying to make that progress and an
emphasis - on the idea that we're not
just as symbolic species are some
bollocks
nature and their inner language
capability make possible and interaction
with
perceptual apparatus that I think would
not be possible in a dog or a chimpanzee
and finally I think as as as part of the
as part of the contribution package I'd
like to say that I think that if we do
all this then we'll have a much better
understanding of how we how we work and
I think that will lead to what I would
like to call with the perhaps a touch of
irony unthinkable value to the species
Thank You Patrick Tommy Poggio tells me
that we have another 15 minutes and I
would hate to let this opportunity pass
with these this extraordinary collection
of speakers without some exploration of
perhaps some themes that cross-cut some
of the presentations I'm going to take
the liberty of asking a couple of
questions myself to try to draw out some
connections among the fascinating
presentations we just heard and I'll
start with with Sydney Brenner
you have inaugurated the study of the
nervous system of a creature with 302
neurons many of us are interested in the
neuroscience of a creature with a
hundred billion 302 neurons give or take
a few hundred thousand and we have heard
this very evening suggestions that the
genetic code contains information that
is exploited in the development of the
capacity say to use human language
together with the thoughts that are
expressed in language you referred
jocularly to the the Chomsky gene that
the single hypothetical gene that that
turns us into a human but more seriously
do you have any thoughts on how we might
eventually narrow the gap between
systems like C elegans where we clearly
have an enormous amount of understanding
and the organism that many of the rest
of us are interested in and the possible
information in the genome that results
in the innate unfolding of cognitive
abilities well I think it has to go
beyond these hardwired systems and I
think there there is a biological
invention that occurred which allowed us
which allowed us to expand the
possibilities of the system if I can
give one example
of this I think that thing that would be
extremely interesting to ask is it just
going to be more of the same stuff that
somehow culminates in intelligence and
all the other properties associated well
is there some revolutionary change in
principle so I think the important thing
is in that once we have we get away and
have a way of building bigger nervous
systems we have the potential then to
have not fix it there's a there are many
such systems in biology the immune
system is it says you can learn things
from the past which is - by animals
being selected because of things but you
must have a way of meeting unforeseen
circumstances and I think we have to
have something like that needn't be
coded like the immune system we have to
have a flexible system in which we can
achieve the result but we need
additional input of experience if you
like so perhaps our genomes only decide
how to make a baby
and all the rest of it has to follow but
they give you the capacity to do these
things and that is the that I think it's
the very interesting thing on the other
hand I am still very interested in the
accumulation that comes from the
processes of evolution and evolution of
course naturally selects for organisms
and so to speak guarantees their
survival in fact it could be argued
that the trouble with us as human beings
is that we stopped biological evolution
we're sitting inside of ourselves is a
quarter of a million year old genome
totally unsuited Mel adapted to the
environment we need to create we that we
that we've created as part of history
and I think we should we should be clear
about that because there is still if you
like deep down inside there is an animal
and the animal is still very much like a
rat or a mouse of course doesn't do the
same things but it is designed a system
designed for function for survival I
think what we've been able to do by the
expansion of other parts of the brain is
in fact in many cases to be able to
suppress it I think is a very good
example of you can receive this very
clearly and that's why I think the basic
part of the brain that we can still
explain from the genome and all these
other things resides in the hypothalamus
the hypothalamus is Freud's it alright
now what happens is the frontal cortex
sends inhibitory stimulus down to the
high percent element since they stop
behaving like a beast you know so all
those things which we regret in our
constitution like greed lust desire
avarice those are encoded really in the
genes that affect the hypothalamus and
what we have is thus inhibitory thing so
that means that we can suppress this and
sometimes we don't want to or can't and
so on so I think that the layering of
this
which distinguishes that and therefore
you will have to work in this field here
that looks at this everybody knows that
you can take if you take a rat and let
it smell a cat has to smell it that's
encoded in the genome and it undergoes
complete panic
of course you can condition that to the
vision of a cat then you show the animal
a cat complete panic
you take it out and you just destroy
3000 cells in its hypothalamus and you
put it back in the cage you can show it
the cat
it'll swarm - out of this walk in front
of a cat the amusing thing now the cat
is perplexed however I just give you
that and I think a lot of this is I
think in this and I think this is where
biology can tell you what the ground
process is what encoded in our genes
many things are like that but I think
the rest of it is all the other stuff
that we've seen so we have if you like a
machine within a machine we have an
added on top of this a machine which is
capable of flexibility which is capable
of changing so that's why I don't
believe that tracing out all the
connections I think that's a form of
insanity and then we'll be able to
discover exactly this I think that is a
form of insanity I mean today nobody can
describe to you in detail all the
physical events occur in a in a computer
chip when you take a picture in your in
your camera which has the telephone
attached
to it and nobody wants to describe it
anymore
because the basic principles are there
we've got above it so I think we have to
look at the still with the sole thing of
layers of organization and we must learn
to know what we can do and what others
can do together with us that's why it's
got to be multiple disciplinary thank
you I have a question for both Norma and
Marvin that I think is on the minds of
many people in this room and I know it's
been expressed in some of the questions
that I've received by email prior to
this event that there is a narrative in
which the new direction of both
artificial intelligence and cognitive
science is one that makes a great deal
more use of probabilistic information
that is gleaned from enormous amounts of
experience during learning this is a
manifested in branches of cognitive
science such as neural networks and
connectionism Bayesian inference models
application of machine learning to
intelligence many of the models both of
Tommy Poggio and Josh Tenenbaum in the
classic work from the Golden Age and
indeed in many of the models since then
including the models of generative
grammar and models of semantic memory
probabilities don't play a big role is
the narrative that says that the
direction of the field is in making use
of massive amounts of statistical
information via learning well maybe I'll
ask you to complete that sentence what
is the well let you complete the
sentence No
I mean it's true there's been a lot of
work on trying to apply statistical
models to various linguistic problems I
think there's been some successes but a
lot of failures these successes to my
knowledge at least you know there's no
time to go into details but the
successes that I know of are those that
integrate statistical analysis with some
a universal grammar property some
fundamental properties of language when
they're integrated you sometimes do get
results it's the simplest case maybe is
the problem of identifying words in a
running discourse something apparently
children do you know they hear a running
discourse they pick out units and the
obvious units are words which are really
phonological units and and there's a
natural property that I wrote about it
in the 1950s I mean it was taken for
granted that if you just take a look at
the if you have a series of sounds and
you look at the transitional
probabilities at each point what's
likely to come next when you get to a
word boundary the probabilities go way
down you don't know what's coming next
if it's internal to a word you can
predict pretty well so if you kind of
trace transitional probabilities you
ought to get something like word
boundaries that's just I wrote about
1955 and I assumed that that's correct
turns out to be false it was shown
actually by Charles yang a former
student here
PhD in the computer science department
that if you apply that method it
basically gives syllables in a language
like English on the other hand if you
apply that message under a constraint
namely the constraint that a
word has what's called a prosaic pink
you know like a pitch stress pink which
is true then then you get much better
results now there's more recent work
which is still impressed by shukla
Ashland and others which shows that you
get still better results if you apply
that together with what are called pros
otic phrases I mean it turns out that
the you know an express a sentence let's
say has units a units of pitch and
stress and so on which are connected
related to the syntactic structure
actually in ways which were studied
maybe first seriously by another former
student Lisa Selkirk a colleague of
Barbara but when you connect when you
interact Prasad ik Peaks with
transitional probabilities then you get
a pretty good identification of word
boundaries well you know that's the kind
of work that I think makes sense if you
and there are more complex examples but
it's a simple example of the kind of
thing that can work on the other hand
there's a lot of work which tries to do
sophisticated statistical analysis you
know Bayesian so on and so forth
without any concern for the actual
structure of language as far as I'm
aware that only achieves success in a
very odd sense of success there is a
notion of success which has developed in
computational cognitive science in
recent years which i think is novel in
the history of science it interprets
success as approximating unanalyzed data
so for example if you were say to study
B communication this way instead of
doing the complex experiments that B
scientists do you know like having bees
fly to an
to see if they have leaving a trail and
this sort of thing if you simply did
extensive videotaping of bees swarming
okay and you did you know a lot of
statistical analysis of it you would get
a pretty good prediction for what these
are likely to do next time they swarm
actually get a better prediction than
bee scientists do and they wouldn't care
because they're not trying to do that
but and you can make it a better and
better approximation buy more videotapes
and more statistics and so on if it
actually could do physics this way
instead of studying things like balls
rolling down frictionless planes which
can't happen in nature if you took a ton
of videotapes of what's happening
outside my office window let's say
leaves flying and various things and you
did an extensive analysis of them you
would get some kind of prediction of
what's likely to happen next
certainly way better than anybody in the
physics department could you well that's
a notion of success which is I think
novel I don't know of anything like it
in history of science and in in those
terms you get some kind of successes and
if you look at the literature in the
field a lot of these papers are listed
as successes and when you look at them
carefully they're successes in this
particular sense and not the sense that
science has ever been interested in but
it does give you ways of approximating
unanalyzed data you know analysis corpus
and so on and so forth I don't know of
any other cases frankly so there are
successes where things are integrated
with some of the properties of language
but I know we say no none in which
they're not thank you to my tremendous
regret and I imagine of many people in
the audience I'm gonna have to bring the
proceedings to a close and we'll have to
be left with Patrick's interpretation of
what Marvin's response would have been
to the question I'd like to thank Sydney
Brenner Marvin Minsky Noam Chomsky
Emilio beatsie Barbara party patrick
winston for a new norm
sleaze stimulating session and thanks